IT'S BOUND TO MELT YOUR MIND,
THE NEXT GUEST IS THE AUTHOR OF
SIX BESTSELLERS WHICH IS MORE
THAN I HAVE, SO I HATE HIM FOR
ITS.
HIS NEW BOOK HAS MARXIST DOPES
ON THE ROPES, IT'S CALLED
AMERICAN MARXISM JOINING IS NOW
AUTHOR AND HOST OF LIFE, LIBERT
AND LEVINE, MARK LEVINE, HOW AR
YOU?
TO GET WONDERFUL, HOW ARE YOU,
GREG.
>> I HAVE BEEN PRACTICING.
WE'RE ALREADY OFF TO A BAD STAR
BECAUSE I MISPRONOUNCED HER NAME
, AND BECOME AT THE AUDIENCE
APPLAUDED FOR YOU LOUDER THAN
THEY DID FOR ME.
PLUS, YOU SOLD 400,000 BOOKS IN
YOUR FIRST WEEK.
WHICH IS LIKE INSANE, SHOULD DI
TAKE THAT AS A GOOD SIGN THAT
AMERICA IS NOT GOING TO HELL?
>> THINK HE REALLY SHOULD.
I LOVE THE LEFT THEY SAY WHAT
YOU MEAN I'M A MARXIST, GLITZY,
REDISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH, CLASS
WARFARE, YOU HATE CAPITALISM,
YOU TALK ABOUT OVERTHROWING OUR
SOCIETY, YOU OPPOSE FREE SPEECH
AND ACADEMIC LIBERTY, THAT KIND
DEFINES IT, BUT I'M NOT REALLY
CALLING THEM MARXIST, THEIR
AMERICAN MARXIST, THEY'RE NOT
SOVIET STYLE MARXIST OR MOUNT
TYPES OF MARXIST, THEY'RE
HOMEGROWN TYPES OF MARXIST
SPIRIT.
>> AND WE GREW THEM.
OUR ACADEMIC CULTURE, THERE NOW
IN HUMAN RESOURCES, THEY'RE ALL
OVER.
MY PROBLEM IS, MARKET, WHEN YOU
TALK TO PEOPLE ABOUT SOCIALISM
AND COMMUNISM, MARXISM COMING
AFTER WORK BACKWARDS AND DEFINE
THOSE TERMS FOR THEM NOW BECAUS
IT'S LIKE THEY FORGOTTEN IT.
>> PEOPLE TAKE TO SAY TO ME YOU
CALLING THESE CORPORATIONS
MARXIST, IT'S AMERICAN MARXISM,
WHAT EXACTLY DO I MEAN LIKE THAT
?
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS IF YOU G
BACK AND YOU LOOK FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE COMES FROM, IT COMES FRO
THE DE- GROWTH MOVEMENT IN THE
1970s AND YOUR, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT CRITICAL RACE THEORY WHICH
COMES AT A CRITICAL THEORY, IT
WAS INVENTED BY A MARXIST FROM
THE FRANKLIN SCHOOL OF MARXISM.
WHEN YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT TH
ROOT CAUSES OF THESE THINGS,
THAT'S WHAT IT IS SO I'M SICK
AND TIRED OF CALLING PEOPLE
PROGRESSIVES, THAT'S WHAT THEY
WANT TO BE CALLED OR I'M A
SOCIAL ACTIVIST.
YOU KNOW WHAT A SOCIAL ACTIVIST
IS?
A GIRL SCOUT TRYING TO SELL GIR
SCOUT COOKIES, THESE ARE PEOPLE
TRYING TO OVERTHROW OUR COUNTRY.
TO GET YOU BRO GOT UP CRT.
I THINK PART OF THE REASON
THINGS LIKE THAT HAVE SUCCESS I
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN SECRET
INCOHERENT LANGUAGE THAT IS
MEANT TO CONFUSE PEOPLE SO WHEN
PEOPLE FIGHT IT THEY SAY NO,
IT'S A DESTRUCTIVE IDEOLOGY, AN
THEN YOU HAVE TO EXPLAIN IT, AN
I FIND THE BEST WAY TO FIGHT
THIS STUFF IS TO CREATE A SIMPL
DEFINITION OF WHAT IT IS, WHICH
IS CRT IS ESSENTIALLY A RACIST
IDEOLOGY, WOULDN'T YOU AGREE?
>> I'VE GOT ONE FOR YOU, I WOUL
CALL IT LOUIS FARRAKHAN DRESSED
UP A SCHOLARSHIP.
HE'S A BIGOT, HE'S A RACIST, HE
HATES WHITE PEOPLE, HE'S AN
ANTI-SEMITE, IT SOUNDS LIKE
CRITICAL RACE THEORY TO ME.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU A STORY
BACK IN THE DAYS OF REDEYE MET
MIKE BERGER GOT AN E-MAIL FROM
MARK LEVIN THAT SHOULD'VE BEEN
THE TITLE OF THE SHOW FRIDAY
NIGHT.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW IT'S NOT?
>> GOOD POINT.
SO I WAS SO EXCITED THAT YOU AR
COMING ON THE SHOW, AND THEN OF
COURSE IT'S NOT YOU, IT'S A
DIFFERENT ONE IT SOME LAWYER
FROM NEW JERSEY,.
>> HE'S A SCHMUCKER.
>> BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, MIKE
BOOKER WOULDN'T TELL ME UNTIL
THE DAY OF SO I'M SO EXCITED
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE ON THE
PANEL HAS TO BE IN 2008 AND 200
AND THE GUY SITTING THERE A SAI
THAT IS NOT HIM, THAT IS NOT HI
I HAD ALL THESE QUESTIONS, BY
THE WAY, JESSE WATTERS, VERY
LUCKY THAT HIS BOOK IT CAME OUT
THE WEEK BEFORE YOURS DID
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT, VERY
LUCKY.
>> I WILL JUST SAY THIS.
ME JUST SAY THIS.
WHO KNOWS, BUT THIS BOOK REALLY
HAS TAKEN OFF, WE ARE GOING INT
THE FOURTH WEEK, WE'RE AT OVER
700,000 COPIES ALREADY.
THERE IS A MOVEMENT AFOOT, I
DON'T THINK THE MEDIA
UNDERSTANDS IT, THERE IS A
MOVEMENT AFOOT, IT'S A BIG
MOVEMENT, IS GOING TO BE
EFFECTUATED IN 2020 TO, BUT MOR
THAN THAT, YOU WILL SEE A RISE
LIKE YOU DID WITH THE TEA PARTY
AND THE REAGAN REVOLUTION, THES
ARE ALL THINGS I WAS INVOLVED IN
, I SEE IT, SMELL IT, TASTED,
IT IS HERE.
>> I HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT.
THAN